it was the most important gathering to
end
Libya's conflict in many years but from
the start
German Chancellor Angela Merkel was
struggling to narrow differences between
Libya's rivals prime minister of the
tripoli based government of national
accord fazer suraj refused to sit down
with warlord halifa after leaving merkel
shuttling back and forth to convince
major powers to help secure a permanent
ceasefire and stop the flow of arms into
the war-torn country everyone was in
agreement including the regional
organisations the Arab League the EU and
of course the African Union that we need
a political solution it's become evident
in the last few weeks that there's no
chance for a military solution which
could only increase the suffering of the
Libyan people the UN chief said the new
diplomatic gains made so far boost the
chances for a new political process
owned and led by the Libyans we are all
bein parties to engage in a Libyan owned
and Libyan a dialogue and the auspices
of United Nations paving the way for a
political solution to the crisis despite
the consensus among the participants of
the conference there remains huge
disagreements French president Emmanuel
macron called for an immediate end to
foreign intervention Paris has recently
expressed concerns over turkeys growing
influence but for president recep tayyip
erdogan Turkey's role is crucial - and
violence and prevent hafte from
capturing Tripoli we have been trying on
a number of occasions to have a
ceasefire agreement signed the national
government of Accords signed a ceasefire
agreement yes it wasn't signed by the
other party led by huff Todd if we fail
to have a ceasefire in place and if we
fail to have an agreement signed we will
never see huffed as hostilities coming
to an end
Russia is also expanding its influence
in Libya but appears to be willing to
team up with Turkey to ensure the
ceasefire
holls even though both countries support
opposite sides of the conflict we thank
both the parties for coming to moscow as
they both had heeded our calls and they
had both responded to our demands of a
ceasefire now we are in Berlin we hope
for more success in this particular
crisis the u.s. role has significantly
diminished in the oil-rich country the
EU is divided the French support after
while the Italians back Siraj there were
hopes the Berlin conference will bring
all the parties that can end the
conflict but Tunisia was shunned from
the peace talks after receiving an
invitation last-minute Morocco which
hosted the 2015 peace talks and Qatar a
key supporter of the GNA were also
excluded the Berlin conference was
essentially about relaunching political
dialogue Libyan rival groups will meet
in Geneva in the coming weeks to see if
they can form a new government or risk
turning their country into a permanent
playground for foreign intervention
Hashima aljazeera Berlin Mohamed
Abdullahi days in Tripoli he says the
situation there remains fragile and
there's some skepticism that a lasting
deal can be reached it's still so
fragile during this ceasefire but it
seems that what's going on in Berlin is
in another I mean it's going on another
pass because there are so many
hardliners here on both sides who do not
want to stop the fighting and in fact
the people here many people here believe
that the Berlin talks are meant to
bridge the gap between the countries
involved in Libya not between the Libyan
arrival arrivals and now here for
example the Western camp led by the UN
recognized the Prime Minister Fayyad
Siraj they say that they cannot trust
hefter and they cannot make peace with
heffner's camp unless he is tried for
what they call the war crimes that have
been committed by his forces since April
the force since they launched the
military
campaign to seize Tripoli they there
have been so many question marks they
have been addressing these the military
capped the military camp on the ground
because many military leaders on the
ground they say that they cannot hand
over their weapons and they cannot stop
fighting until half the resources are
pushed out of southern a Tripoli
meanwhile on the and the east of the
country the military brigades supporting
the world Lord relief after and they
have taken control of the oil terminals
they say that they cannot accept any
foreign intervention in Libya they mean
the Turkish military assistance to the
government of national Accord now the
conference in Berlin was also
overshadowed by a blockade of Libya's
major oil fields by Khalifa Haftar
forces which is threatening to choke
production in recent months Libya's been
producing 1.2 million barrels per day as
the country's largest export oil is a
financial lifeline for the UN recognized
government in Tripoli after's allies
have shut down for oil pipelines forcing
the closure of two of the country's
largest oil fields now the closures will
slash Libya's output by more than 90
percent to just 72 thousand barrels per
day the US Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo says that he's glad to see
progress towards peace but wants to see
Libya's oil pipelines are reopened
there's still a lot of work to do
it's a complicated battlefield but you
add
president hairdo on President Putin
jessa4 cold all making a sincere
commitment Special Representative Salome
who's running the UN file making this
sincere commitment and said we're going
to do this we're going to reduce risk
we're going to conduct the cease fire
still some questions about it how well
and how effectively can monitor this but
I'm optimistic